Das Konzept des Fundamentalismus ist im Wesentlichen verknüpft mit
dem Konzept der Messung in der Quantenmechanik.
Bevor die Quantenmechanik entwickelt wurde,
war es unter Wissenschaftlern allgemein bekannt,
dass wenn du ein System hast, das sich
in einem bestimmten Zustand befindet
und du eine Messung daran durchführst, wirst du
ein klar definiertes Ergebnis bekommen.
In der Quantenmechanik ist das nicht mehr so. Du kannst
ein System haben, das sich in einem perfekt definierten Zustand befindet,
und trotzdem, wenn du bestimmte
Messungen daran vornimmst, kannst du zufällige Ergebnisse bekommen.
Um dieses Konzept zu veranschaulichen, muss ich
das Konzept der Superposition einführen.
Superposition ist ein Konzept, das nicht auf Quantenphysik beschränkt ist.
Es basiert auf dem gleichzeitigen Vorliegen
mehrerer Linearkombinationen von Zuständen.
Du kannst es dir vorstellen
wie zum Beispiel eine Radiowelle, die
viele verschiedene Frequenzen trägt. Daran ist nichts
inhärent Quantenmechanisches.
Was der Superposition ihren quantenmechanischen Charakter verleiht, ist die Tatsache
des Messens des Systems.
Ich werde das an einem Beispiel veranschaulichen.
Stell dir vor, du hast ein System von Pfeilen,
und du präparierst das System
so, dass alle Pfeile nach links zeigen.
Dann gehst du hin und
stellst jedem Pfeil die Frage: Zeigst du nach oben oder nach unten?
Und jeder Pfeil antwortet. Da die Pfeile nach links zeigen und das
als Überlagerung beschrieben werden kann,
nämlich als Linearkombination zwischen
oben und unten, wirst du
als Ergebnis zu fünfzig Prozent oben
und zu fünfzig Prozent unten erhalten, wenn du fragst: Zeigst du nach oben?
Du bekommst dieses Ergebnis vom System.
Dann kannst du das System in
einem anderen Zustand präparieren, bei dem die Hälfte der Pfeile nach oben
und die andere Hälfte nach unten zeigt,
und du stellst die gleiche Frage —
und du bekommst das gleiche Ergebnis.
Es sind zwei sehr unterschiedliche Systeme,
und du hast diese Information bekommen.
Und jetzt stellt sich die Frage:
Wie kannst du den Unterschied feststellen? Die
Systeme sind sehr unterschiedlich,
weil du im ersten Fall das System in
einem reinen Zustand präpariert hast, den du
das System fragen kannst und der dir ein deterministisches
Ergebnis liefert. Diese Frage lautet: Zeigst du nach links oder rechts?
Es wird dir zu hundert Prozent sagen: links.
Im zweiten Fall gibt es keine Frage, die du stellen kannst,
die dir zu hundert Prozent ein bestimmtes Ergebnis liefert,
weil es sich um eine Mischung handelt.
Wenn du also links oder rechts fragst,
wird es zufällig sein, weil die Hälfte nach oben zeigt
und die andere nach unten. Fragst du oben oder unten,
gilt das gleiche — es werden fünfzig Prozent sein.
Wie hängt das mit Zufälligkeit zusammen?
Du kannst dir das vorstellen als
das Werfen einer Münze — es wird Kopf oder Zahl sein.
Aber es ist nicht wie das Werfen einer Münze.
Weil wenn du eine Münze wirfst,
der einzige Grund, warum du das Ergebnis nicht kennst,
ist, dass du nicht weißt,
mit welcher Energie du die Münze geworfen hast, den Winkel, den Impuls,
die Umgebungsbedingungen im Raum
und so weiter. Wenn du all diese
Variablen kennen würdest, könntest du Kopf oder Zahl vorhersagen. Das sind
versteckte Variablen, die dem Beobachter verborgen sind.
Und viele Jahre lang glaubten Wissenschaftler, dass es
ähnliche verborgene Variablen in der Quantenmechanik gibt, die sich
als Zufälligkeit offenbaren würden.
Und erst mit der
wegweisenden Arbeit von John Bell in den Sechzigern wurde tatsächlich
gezeigt, dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Und heute anerkennt jeder Physiker,
dass es keine verborgene
Variablentheorie gibt, die mit der Quantenmechanik vereinbar ist.
Es ist also wirklich wahr: Wenn du ein System misst,
offenbart die Natur das Ergebnis zufällig.
Egal wie lange ich darüber nachdenke —
ich finde das einfach erstaunlich.